[Music]
hey what is up guys i'm kbhd here and
it's that time of year again with all
sorts of device stuff and reviews new
gadgets and of course dope tech right
around the corner but i wanted to take
this opportunity to quickly introduce
you to a new creation
mkbhd.com so there's all kinds of
different ways to use a website as a
youtuber and also a whole bunch of
different reasons too as well
mkbhd.com is going to be a sort of a
secondary hub for stuff that can't
otherwise go on the youtube channel so
it should be able to host stuff like
photo samples from new smartphone
cameras that's something i have up there
now and other stuff like little written
tidbits every now and then infographics
little diagrams just stuff to accompany
the videos that i couldn't otherwise put
in the video itself so that's the kind
of stuff that's up there right now and
then it's also going to be sort of a hub
for any sort of merch related stuff so
right now that means the one day left to
get an mkbhd version 2 plugged in t and
also a brand new store with dbrand so
you know how i've said before i'm not
really a big cases on smartphones kind
of guy and nine times out of 10 if a
phone is slippery or if i feel the need
to change the look or texture then i'll
just grab a skin for it so for different
phones i have different styles of skin
that i would usually want to get usually
carbon fiber usually red or black and in
the dbrand mkbhd store you can actually
for any phone they support grab a skin
in the exact configuration that i would
get it so pick a phone any phone check
out the listing and that's the skin i
would grab for it it's a three pack and
there's cutouts where i would get them
no cutouts why i wouldn't etc now of
course the site is super early this is
day one so it has plenty of room to grow
and that's actually what i want to focus
on is branching out and making it good
at other things and i'll eventually add
stuff like i think a gear list is
something i want to add because right
now the gear list of things i use is
just the amazon link that i have in the
description and half the stuff i use
isn't on amazon anymore anyway so that
would kind of be a nice thing to host on
the site a much prettier much more
complete version of a gear list
and then maybe other stuff that i want
to host like for example you guys asked
for like raw video samples or 3ds from
the weapon camera i'm using that kind of
thing or maybe other files that i want
to host but yeah it's early so go over
check it out definitely let me know what
you think and leave any feedback my way
send it to me on twitter hit me up let
me know now i say on twitter because the
comment section below is for a fun
little giveaway
these are two nexus 5xs
two of them i don't need two so one of
them i'm going to be giving away so if
you live anywhere on earth it's an
international giveaway for the next one
week feel free to leave a comment below
about nexus 5x and i'll pick one random
lucky winner and announce that winner on
twitter so you're definitely going to
want to follow over there and yes the
review of this guy along with its bigger
brother and many other crispy things are
coming up very soon spoiler i like it a
lot anyway yeah that's it for the quick
update the site is now live for those of
you who've been waiting for it to check
out and give us feedback and it will
definitely be growing as we get ideas
anyway thanks for watching this one and
i'll talk to you guys in the next one
peace
[Music]